et en france les sénateurs votent
jusqu'à ce soir le projet de loi
transformant le pass and it est en passe
vaccinale avec des ajustements hier soir
le sénat a supprimé la possibilité pour
les patrons de bars cafés et restaurants
de vérifier l'identité des détenteurs du
pass n'est pas seulement alors pour en
savoir plus on va tout de suite retrouvé
notre reporter david khalifa devant le
sénat
[Musique]
bonjour david alors l'examen en première
lecture du projet de loi hier a déjà
donné lieu à quelques modifications
significatives avant un vote final qui
aura lieu demain
si tout se passe bien olivier en fr le
pass vaccinale doit être adopté par le
sénat et des à demain avec des
modifications significatives à prouver
dès hier soir vous l'avez évoqué la
suppression de la possibilité de
vérifier l'identité des détenteurs du
pass pour les patrons de bars et
restaurants autres modifications
majeures que le gouvernement ne souhaite
pas voir inscrite dans la loi
l'extinction automatique du pass
vaccinale qui pourrait en effet être
imposée que lorsque le nombre
d'hospitalisations liées au coût de 19
serait supérieure à dix mille patients
au plan national et disparaîtrait
automatiquement en deçà de ce seuil une
mesure vivement contestée par olivier
verts ont écouté
le mettre dans la loi ne pose des
difficultés majeures parce que nous
sommes face à des situations qui nous
montre vague après vague qu'ils sont
imprévisibles
personne n'aurait pu si nous avions du
riz envisager un seuil par exemple le
nombre de contaminations dans notre pays
déclenchant des mesures sanitaires qui
aurait pu prédire qu'un jour nous
aurions 350000 contamination 24 heures
donc le seuil surtout dans la loi est
rigide et nous empêchent d'agir en
revanche les dispositions actuelles en
matière d'application du pass vaccinale
renvoie à la notion d'urgence sanitaire
ne sont légitimes et que pour des motifs
sanitaires et s'il s'avérait que la
situation épidémique et sanitaire
n'était plus jugé compatible avec le
maintien du pass la justice la justice
ordonnerait à ce que ce dispositif tombe
à ce jour les hôpitaux compte plus de 25
mille malades du kobe d'aujourd'hui sur
lui parce vaccinale est voté il faudrait
donc pouvoir justifier d'un statut
vaccinal pour accéder aux activités de
loisirs restaurants et bars foire ou
transports publics inter-régionaux un
test ne suffirait plus pour accéder sauf
pour accéder aux établissements de santé
alors d'amis de l'exécutif contrarié
dans ses plans il reste encore une
centaine d'âmes on a examiné pour les
sénateurs alors quoi est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre
plusieurs choses effectivement devrait
être modifié le président l ère du sénat
gérard larcher a répété que l'équilibré
était primordial pour la défense des
libertés contre l'avis du gouvernement
les sénateurs ont prévu de limiter la
possibilité d'imposer la présentation
d'un pass vaccinale aux personnes de
plus de 18 ans les mineurs âgés de 12 à
17 ans resterait soumis aux passes
sanitaire modifications possibles et
également la suppression de la vente de
1000 euros par employé pour non-respect
du télétravail le retrait des centres
commerciaux écran magasin de la liste
des établissements elle nécessite en
impasse vaccinale voici les principaux
points d'achoppement qui seront étudiées
au sénat elle cet après midi en revanche
les sénateurs ont d'ores et déjà
instauré hier soir à des jauges
proportionnelle dans les stades et les
salles de spectacle est limitée à 5000
les établissements extérieurs pourront
désormais ouvrir 50 % des places
restantes alors une fois est ces
derniers amendements examinés à députés
et sénateurs se réuniront en commission
mixte paritaire pour tenter de trouver
un accord sur une version commune en cas
de désaccord c'est l'assemblée qui aura
le dernier mot l entrée en vigueur du
texte pour être effective le 17 janvier
un prochain ce qui est ce qui signifie
un léger retard dans le calendrier de
l'exécutif et ce qui contrarie un peu le
gouvernement merci beaucoup david pour
toutes ces précisions david khalifa en
direct devant le sénat à paris et puis